tuxedo slippers
excuse me
i'm supposed to meet you here
huh
are you wesley i'm carol i'm sorry
what's happening now i'm supposed to
meet a wesley about my insurance claim
wesley doesn't work here anymore are you
serious i mean i made the appointment
like a month ago i rearranged my whole
saturday
are you a doorman yeah i'm a doorman
to the sky i'm a pilot oh
okay well look it's a pretty standard
workman's comp claim i'm sure you could
handle it i was flying the 7 a.m from
tampa to louisville and we had a
two-hour weather delay so naturally all
the passengers got drunk generally
speaking if there's a delay of more than
20 minutes i might as well be driving a
party bus it's just
idiocy i don't know what's going on in
this country i know people wear
flip-flops to church and the nba tattoo
situation is out of control thank you
anyway we're about a half hour into the
flight i hear this commotion behind me
in the cabin so i exit the cockpit i go
down the aisle and to my left i see a
terrorist no i wish no it's a drunk lady
she's pulled her pants off and she's
ranting she's complaining about the
in-flight entertainment so
things got a little heated and uh i had
to implement sky law what's sky law it's
when i put on the fasten seat belt sign
and no one's allowed to move till we've
had 10 minutes of silence
i made the whole thing up but you know
people are stupid so they don't question
it
that is awesome
so what is the workman's comp part of
this eventually i flipped the drunk lady
off she bit my finger
i know i was totally unprofessional but
she was bagging pretty hard on my tgs
what tgs it's this late night show on
nbc we run it in flight when we're
northwest bound
basically the greatest thing ever on
television
i don't stand for anybody be smurching
it on my aircraft
do you believe in fate
[Music]
wait are you kidding me you write for
tgs with tracy jordan i'm the head
writer i'm not an insurance claims
adjuster i'm just here because
my cousin
[Music]
well i mean it's my favorite show ever
there's the one
fart doctor sketch where his fart
doctor's trying to figure out who farted
in the spelling bee and he's like hey
who spelled it dealt it i wrote that i
write all the fart doctors i can't
believe this
would you like to go to a rich girl's
wedding with me i don't know does that
sound like more fun than me eating alone
at the laguardia
you chili's
to watch tv
first thing you need is tequila stop
waiting barefoot contessa i love this
show me too
this is one of the three things in the
world i like ina garten sweater weather
and when muppets presented award shows
well yes me too
we really see eye to eye on a lot of
stuff don't we absolutely i've never met
anyone before who had the exact same
idea as me about what to do with
palestine it would work right of course
it would work and don't you agree that
our situation is perfect right now you
have these great visits together but
then we still have our separate lives
we're like jeffrey and aina
no no i can't i can't live like this
anymore
not like jeffrey
i'm not as strong as that guy don't have
too much fun without it okay i need to
know where this relationship is going
and i can feel you resisting it
no
no it okay
don't be cry
i'm a pilot liz you know i spent my
entire adult life just
casual girlfriends in different cities
and
i i i can't go from woman to woman to
woman anymore
how many women have you been with no no
i'd i'd rather not say
it's shameful
and i'm a pilot
six
that's not so great i want grown-up love
[Music]
[Laughter]
folks from the flight deck it looks like
it's gonna be about another half hour
and then we'll be on our way uh
i have an announcement our pilot has
gone insane no don't listen to her don't
having seen crimson tide on showtime
last weekend i believe the only course
of action available to us is passenger
mutiny i am denzel i am invoking skylaw
you are now silenced shrieking harpy
stop speaking we could have gone back to
a gate and he wouldn't take us
do not blame me i wouldn't take us
because she wouldn't admit to being
wrong for challenging my authority why
not what's wrong with you i am right he
knows it he could have given us food
maybe this is one of those times when
both of you just say on the count of
three i was wrong one two three never
how are you two dating you're too
similar
where are you going i am pulling the
emergency exit slide and we are all
getting off of this plane i'll be a folk
hero like that guy everybody hates now
don't you even think about it that is a
federal offense just try to stop me oh
you be careful what you wish for
i will waste you you'll have to go
through this old bastard first
oh we can still be friends
carol i knew you wouldn't forget about
me today no non-essential chat or liz
i'm having the worst flight of my career
we got wind shear lightning severe
turbulence the in-flight meal was a
frittata
oh my god at night lizzy if something
were to happen i just i want you to know
that i
i need you to go to raleigh to my
apartment and just clear out all the
porn before my mom gets there
that's it yeah i also need you to tivo
bones for me in case i survive no you
know what carol today is a very special
day and you should have known that and
you should also know that you can't use
cell phones on planes
no that's just something we tell
passengers hello hold on
all right yeah i think i just screwed up
something with my girlfriend you know
i've always loved you
not now kevin
you